[Music]
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the show
my name is wayne dupree and you are
looking live at
the best conservative show that is out
there that cares about you and cares
about
what you hear here on the interweb
uh let me introduce my i we got a whole
lot to talk about and short down the
door so let me introduce my co-host
blue eyes leah bella hello make sure you
are sharing
the show liking it and commenting so
share the show i know i said that every
day and i hope i not like just talking
to you well i really mean it
share the show let that be your
christmas gift to us
share the show and i'll tell you a joke
yeah you do not want this woman joke no
she phyllis diller she's not oh
no oh man phyllis diller was she made
a cameo on scooby-doo i love that
did everybody do scooby-doo or was that
just me
even the basketball team did scooby-doo
remember when they did it
i was awesome i couldn't think for a
minute i'm too busy focused on my joke
i'm getting ready to tell because
everybody's sharing the show
no they want to hear the joke theresa
wants to hear the joke okay
elaine wants to hear the joke all of you
in the chat room right now and it wants
to hear
leah's christmas joke share the show and
tell me you shared it
type the number one and and and
and share the show type question one
push one
to hear a joke
[Music]
oh
you guys this joke you're going to be
able to use
tomorrow and on christmas day to your
whole family and they're going to love
you for it they're going to love you for
it
ready oh my gosh look at all these ones
we're getting it we're getting it all
right we got a lot of shares couple more
shares
do one and then hit the share thank you
who is that
diane sp
[Laughter]
maybe you're her spy's watching yeah oh
no yeah i ain't gonna do that yeah i'm
not gonna do that yeah
wendy says do it all right wendy davis
that'll be good okay here it goes ready
better be good i know what if i mess it
up
pressure's on yeah okay
what did adam say to eve
the night before christmas
it's christmas eve it's christmas eve
sound effects not side effects
i want to thank our great patreon
some people said they thought it was
funny yeah yeah they feel sorry for you
south side baby said dry jokes
hey that's been my little joke for a
very long time since i've been little
phoenix said eat my cherry pie um
i have no idea
that's from the 80s
uh rock band they weren't anyone
else come on
you know what you know what i i'm look
any other day i would have banned you
but thank you thank you
that was that was kind of cool okay um
i tried really elia
you're this big job okay um
let's go let's go 600
freaking dollars hey wayne i'm over here
oh oh yes right i'm sorry ladies and
gentlemen the brother reverend pastor
deacon dr bishop over there
miss brian the baptist brian smith
what's up brian
i
there is no room for prejudice
that's cool there's like a hundred
different things on this thing
that's cool
[Laughter]
that's pretty cool kept in the box
though because that's gonna be a
collector's item one day
yours tweets that's gonna be worth a lot
damn thing you figure when the left
takes over and they do communism they're
gonna burn all those so
you should have kept in the box and hit
it somewhere yeah
you don't know how to take care of a
collector's item man okay
six hundred dollars y'all six hundred
dollars president trump got
president trump came up last night and
he shocked a lot of people
from what i'm hearing some people in the
white house didn't want him to do it
they're begging him not to
they asked him don't do it and he went
ahead and did it anyway and
and honestly he didn't do something that
was out of the realm of what he has
asked for in the last couple of months
he told him some of the biscuits to go
big any damn way
yes he told him and and he said
give me your bill don't add nothing else
to it make it big
and make it big and do it quick and do
it quick
yeah and now the democrats are coming
out and the democrats are
saying yo go ahead do it yeah that's
what we wanted
well if that's what you wanted then why
didn't you hold out right
instead of signing the bipartisan bill
for 600 bucks
yeah no you're right i didn't mean to
yeah and then aoc was saying the same
thing
oh we don't even know what's in the bill
but guess what wayne she still signed it
anyways
yeah it doesn't it it it doesn't matter
it did yeah no no and and then they want
to take credit for it
you can't take credit for something that
you signed and then came out
and then gave a press conference saying
oh this is going to help
this is going to be great for the
american people and it's 600 and then
all of a sudden
oh it's two thousand dollars that's what
we wanted in the first place
it just shows me none of them have any
courage
because if they did like you said they
would have got it done in the first
place
now think of this if trump wouldn't have
said anything they were just fine with
the 600
and they could have done 2 000 because
they're doing it now
bad negotiation skills on their part for
for american people
they don't negotiate for the american
people let's wake up and realize they're
negotiating for themselves
and that's it they didn't even try
no it took trump coming out and and
addressing the nation
for them to say all right yeah we can do
2000. that's what we want anyways
then why didn't you speak up right right
he could have said something right
they couldn't they could have said they
could have said anything now
don't get me wrong i'm against spending
in the first place
and i i'm sure everybody on on this
panel is tired of
government spending money that we don't
have i ain't spoken yet
right right but that's not what i'm
angry about i'm angry the fact that
they're not sticking up for us and
they're not doing
something that's better they're lazy
they're trying to get out and go on a
vacation
and then and then my thing and then mr
um mr uh quietness
of um a second but no
my thing is the pandemic is a little bit
different
the pandemic is different because a
whole lot of people lost their jobs and
they haven't got their jobs back right
now what congress did
and then up and then i thought to him
but what congress did
is they thought they were sneaky let's
go ahead and send this
up here with the spending bill send it
up there together
and it's gonna confuse americans it's
gonna confuse everybody
and if he don't sign this if he says he
don't wanna sign this
then he doesn't wanna help period
not nothing he doesn't really do
anything and president trump was like
listen
y'all need to up that thing to two
thousand dollars and then y'all need to
cut some of the spending from that
other bill at the same time he got he
got y'all
and now who's in trouble actually both
of them are really in trouble
the democrats because they're playing
a money game with the american people
with what me and leah just told you
and then the republicans because now the
republicans are back in the corner
because if if they decide that they
don't want to do it
they could lose the two seats in georgia
go ahead god i hope we don't find
other cultures on other planets
because if we do we'll probably america
will probably start sending them checks
yeah that a direct quote from my donald
trump
um yeah this money is out of control
we're talking about a spending package
we're talking about a closing package
we're talking about another couple of
trillion
to put this deficit up to 30 plus
trillion uh let's dial it back if all
remember george bush
we didn't even break 5 trillion under
george bush
i mean we we got right what was it uh no
no we got almost up to 9 trillion
from obama till obama's out was 19
trillion and then now trump 19 to 30
trillion dollars i'll echo rand paul
give everybody a million dollars make us
all rich
guys i don't know my kids
kids kids kids where does it stop
what do we do what i was just i'm beside
myself with all this money it's rain and
money
hallelujah it's right i know everybody's
upset about the 600
and and if you all thought that trump
was conservative
and i'm not bashing trump i'm just
saying who trump really is
trump has always been like this and for
him to call out two thousand dollars i
want bigger money i want bigger money
that's for truly true that's him well
he's got to expect
congress in the senate to do something
different
for those of y'all that said hey we're
back to normal well
we are back to normal to expect congress
and the senate to do something different
is insanity well here's how i feel about
it whenever trump said last night during
his speech
that 1800 dollars was going to illegal
immigrants
and we were only getting 600 there's an
issue there considering that republicans
and democrats both signed off on that
so that tells you who they feel is more
important and that's alarming
also they're sending so much money to
other countries during this covet issue
do you really think other countries care
if we ever get rid of covid because the
more we get covered the more money we
get
the money they get so do you think sudan
really cares that we're all dying from
covet in the u.s
no because they get more money and my
third question is
what the hell is going on at the kennedy
center that they need that much money
oh my god i need to investigate what i
mean
you can't you can't be more on the money
than you are right now about that dan
kennedy center because it seemed like
every time
they put out a stimulus every time they
put out an omnibus bill
they got one they get something it's
like
what has the mafia moved to the kennedy
center
or
either that or every single politician
has got a got some kind of dibs on the
kennedy center
you want to do a special counsel do it
on them
right something i'd be tapping their
wires i'd be spying on them because
something's not right there
i think the irs should do it right
investigation on the filings
of their tax returns every year yeah
it's not sitting right with me really
honestly there should be wiretaps all
through that place because something
isn't right
so all the money that they're talking
about handing out the billions and
billions and billions of dollars talking
about handing out
they could have given a million people
four
thousand dollars a piece yeah four
thousand seven hundred a piece
yeah for a million people do you realize
we're talking about
we got what 380 million people in
america
men women children illegals about 380
million
maybe less do you realize we're talking
about 12
per person in the entire country
and most of that's going overseas yeah
what
we're gonna go and then china will owe
us that's the problem
look i i mean i and i think i speak for
everybody's up here we are pissed off
to the highest highest of festivity
that's a good word to use
we we are seriously looking at the way
that congress is treating us
republicans and democrats alike and you
won't find many many
truthful shows that are going to come
out there and say that both sides
are pieces of crap both sides wayne said
you said it wayne
the rnc they got caught their parents
down yeah they did
this shows you that there probably will
be a third and fourth party
going forward it has to and fracture
and actually you're a kim before
yeah like you said yeah there can be
four you can have it
you can have a dim party you can have a
socialist party within the damn party
you can have republican party and then
you can have mega inside of their
problem
you can really have four parties after
2020.
you're going to see the patriot party
the republican party then you're going
to see the crazy liberal party
and then the democrat party now you
mentioned this the other day is that
what they're calling it
or are they calling it the patriot party
from what i see they're calling it the
patriot party yes
i'm all in tea party members
i'll go in the patreon party i will too
i like it i've seen what they've been
doing i like it
i know one thing they don't like mitch
mcconnell they don't like lindsey graham
the enemy of my enemy is who i'm voting
for
i would love i would love to see mitch's
face
right now because million dollar mitch
is uh he doesn't have to worry about a
six hundred dollar i mean
we're gonna take something he don't care
all the money that his
that his friend and it's not even his
mitch
is a grifter in his own family the tax
tax returns show
that after mitch got married to chow
his tax returns show that he was seems
fine like three million a year
after he got married he was fighting 11
million
22 million his net worth is through the
roof we're talking about republican
we're talking about speaker
the senate leader cocaine mitch
but he's crooked as the day is long he
he's with the demon
he's begging for joe biden to get in oh
yeah
yeah oh yeah absolutely president trump
like we say came out last night
and he laid down the gauntlet
throughout the summer democrats cruelly
blocked covet relief legislation
in an effort to advance their extreme
left-wing agenda
and influence the election then a few
months ago
congress started negotiations on a new
package to get
urgently needed help to the american
people
it's taken forever however the bill they
are now planning
to send back to my desk is much
different
than anticipated it really is a disgrace
for example among the more than 5 000
pages in this bill
which nobody in congress has read
because of its length and complexity
it's called the covet relief bill but it
has almost
nothing to do with covert this bill
contains 85.5 million dollars for
assistance to
cambodia 134 million dollars to burma
1.3 billion dollars for egypt
and the egyptian military which will go
out and buy almost exclusively
russian military equipment 25 million
dollars for
democracy and gender programs in
pakistan
505 million dollars to belize costa rica
el salvador guatemala
honduras nicaragua and panama
40 million dollars for the kennedy
center in washington d.c
which is not even open for business one
billion dollars for the smithsonian
and an additional 154 million dollars
for the national gallery of art
likewise these facilities are
essentially
not open seven million dollars for reef
fish
management 25 billion dollars to combat
asian carp 2.5 million dollars to count
the number of amberjack fish
in the gulf of mexico a provision to
promote
the breeding of fish in federal
hatcheries
three million dollars in poultry
production technology
two million dollars to research the
impact of downed trees
566 million dollars for construction
projects
at the fbi the bill also allows stimulus
checks
for the family members of illegal aliens
allowing them to get up to
one thousand eight hundred dollars each
this is far more than the americans are
given
despite all of this wasteful spending
and much more
the 900 billion package provides
hardworking taxpayers
with only 600 each in relief payments
and not enough money is given to small
businesses
and in particular restaurants whose
owners have suffered so grievously
they were only given a deduction
for others to use in business
their restaurant for two years this
two-year period must be withdrawn
which will allow the owners to obtain
financing
and get their restaurants back in
condition
congress can terminate it at a much
later date but two years
is not acceptable it's not enough
congress found plenty of money for
foreign countries lobbyists and special
interests
while sending the bare minimum to the
american people
who need it it wasn't their fault it was
china's fault not their fault i am
asking congress to amend this bill and
increase the ridiculously low
hundred dollars to two thousand dollars
or
four thousand dollars for a couple i'm
also asking congress to immediately get
rid of the wasteful and unnecessary
items
from this legislation and to send me a
suitable bill
or else the next administration will
have to deliver a coveted relief package
and maybe that administration will be me
and we will get it done
amber fish in the gulf of mexico
did everybody out there that voted for
this bill should be charged
with some kind of crime
this is criminal
it is criminal
folks i'm not mad i'm just passionate
this morning
coming out of me impact of downed trees
three million dollars
to show the impact of down the trees
i'll take
that first if you don't clear it out
it's not fun they're on fire
it's it's not funny it's not what's up
with all the fish
i don't know what is up with all the
fish
hatcheries and it's a joke
does this make you want to pay your
taxes can i just be honest
you want to pay your taxes because that
makes me say i'm not paying them
i'm surprised that they didn't put in
double pad swallow bird
something then all of a sudden now we
need to fund mud flaps for
government vehicles yeah don't forget
the swedish fish
we gotta fund those red swedish fish
candies
i mean seriously like what is up with it
it's just the most random things
and you know what and i'm glad that he
called out those specific things but
the kennedy center is not even open
right
right one billion to the smithsonian
i've been there i'm not that impressed
sorry what do they do
right i have no idea that's what i said
most every single one of them in dc
yeah like that it's going to be a cover
up
yeah i feel billions now that's what i
said it's got to be a cover up they're
laundering they're doing something
that's how you conjure up that's how you
get conspiracy
theories start when you give one billion
dollars a smithsonian and then you go
there and see that it was worth about 25
dollars a ticket
and you're like this was no good you
have to ask yourself what's going on
and then and chuck suppose that with
yeah washington
uh george washington's home in his
estate
you're like what brian what's that got
to do with anything that
is a beautiful pristine estate
fully maintained fully taken care of
with an underground museum
with artifacts and the likes of
information that
nobody's ever taught in school anymore
it's completely 100
private it receives zero dollars
yeah the government the kennedy center
and the smithsonian is definitely
an artery and it is an artery that is
is branching out and and funneling money
or fueling money somehow but it is an
artery
talk about underground railroad there's
something underneath both of those
places
i mean they are running a racket man
they running a racket
you can't spend all you can't spend all
the money that they
are saying that you can spend they are
it's like
i remember i remember after they passed
uh
those two trillion dollar stimulus
omnivorous bills
in 10 months uh in 2017
right under paul ryan right yeah and
then
and then pelosi and schumer are like oh
well now we need a 3 million
3 trillion dollar infrastructure i said
you know what
you know what i know i i know what y'all
are trying to do y'all are trying to
spend as much money as you can under
trump
so it will be more than what barack
obama
had under him so then y'all can tag him
with
you know all the spending that happened
under trump
wreck it yeah because it's coming it's
coming it's coming
and y'all couldn't even give 26 billion
dollars for the wall
oh dj grant said 500 million to jordan
to build a
wait for it border wall
so 500 a half a billion dollars to
jordan to build
a freaking wall yep yep
oh no now now like we said ladies and
gentlemen
the democrats are behind this we're
getting some headlines from speaker
pelosi on how democrats will handle the
president's request for higher
direct payments sue herrera has that sue
i do indeed
ms pelosi the house speaker just sent
out
a letter to her democratic colleagues
and others
basically saying that they are scheduled
to go into a pro forma session tomorrow
at 9 00 a.m we are awaiting word from
leader hoyer as to whether leader
mccarthy
will agree to or reject our unanimous
consent request
basically the president as you know carl
and we have been talking about is asking
for
a much bigger payment uh ms pelosi puts
out the fact that
the republican contingent that she has
been negotiating with
refused to go above the six hundred
dollars so she's basically throwing down
the gauntlet saying
okay let's meet again but she's waiting
to hear back
from leader mccarthy and leader hoyer
but they are scheduled to meet tomorrow
morning at 9 00 a.m
back to you carl shepard smith here
thanks for watching cnbc
every time i see him i just cringe
he's a gay man and a gay journalist he
wants everybody know about them
because he does well i mean if you're a
gay man and a gay journalist and you're
recording
that you are a gay man in a gay journal
why can't why does he have to shout out
to the world why can't he just be normal
and just
whatever who cares because they're not
or whatever okay
[Laughter]
so here's the thing
y'all want to rush back and have a
session but y'all just ran to have a
rush session to sign off on six hundred
dollars
you know what's gonna happen they're
gonna rush back and they're gonna do
something even more nefarious
it's gonna come back it's gonna be
bigger and it's gonna be bigger for all
for it's gonna be bigger for jordan it's
gonna be bigger for everybody you watch
it's kind of there's something trump's
gonna be watching that
well apparently they've got veto proof
as what i'm hearing right now i heard
that too i heard that too
and that and i was explaining to a
friend of mine last night
he didn't veto it he didn't sign it but
he didn't veto it he just told him to go
back
right because he knows that they have
veto power
so so if you just say look
i ain't signed it send it back
work on it and if it don't get done well
it goes to the next administration
because they know if they pass it
through without him signing it they know
it's on their head
exactly right and if if the more money
and you heard trump he said a
thousand per couple or i'm sorry two
thousand per couple is that
i don't know what the kids are getting
it's 2 400 per family
well no trump said go back i want 2 000
per couple 4 000 yeah 4 000.
yeah he did all right just saying be
careful i will say this though
[Laughter]
he going scorched your thumb republicans
i like it that's the trump i like burn
them down is right yeah
yeah i mean look you republicans get
what you deserve
we vote for you we're going straight
mitt romney on you
we're going to burn you down we're going
to let the other ones get voted in we're
going to watch this sink
you guys going to lose control you're
going to lose your money and you're
going to lose power
even local officials uh steve shabbat
you saw what happened in oh
you lost the west side of cincinnati if
you want that to happen again
don't back trump
you know what it's so great i'm so crazy
that um those are crazy that you said
money laundering because
it's what it is makes so much sense
though yeah it has to be that's the only
thing when i saw that last night i
immediately said i looked over and i
said
what's going on at the kennedy center
and then i automatically went to money
laundering because it's the only thing
that i can think of in my head
that even justifies any of that
the money is going somewhere i don't
know i i was always taught to ask as
many questions as i could until i got
the answer that made the most sense
and i keep asking the questions and i'm
not getting any answers
yeah um okay
um that's it and we
and we have been on it the reason why
we've been on it so much is because
it's our money it is
the crazy thing is that the money that
was sent overseas to those foreign
countries
no american had a voice in it
the if it should be like this if
congress wants to do that
then they should have to go back to
their states
yes and get a vote and get approval
by votes absolutely go back to dc
and then propose what the people said
but what they're doing they're just
saying well i'm speaking for
no no you're speaking for yourself
because y'all are getting some money
somehow some way
and then the people you're sending amer
you're sitting in the people of your
state's money overseas without asking
them
yeah there's a couple just a couple
people in suits
deciding where our money goes right
right and we just sit here and say okay
let me run it down real quick for
everybody that's on right now just run
down real quick this is the list
we got the kennedy center 26 mil
smithsonian 1 billion
national art gallery 154 mill humanities
167 mill
wilson center 14 mil now foreign
money that's all domestic foreign money
1.3
billion to egypt the muslim brotherhood
and their army 1.3 billion
to their army 700 million to sudan
453 million to the uk oh
so a half a billion in ukraine tell me
that don't wind up back
up into the democrats pockets don't tell
me
i'm not not that i'm cynical but i've
i've traced the money
we've saw where it goes and now we've
got 500 million
going to israel 130 million going to
paul
nepal 135 million to burma
85 million to cambodia 25 million to
pakistan
and 1.4 billion to asia riaa
when was the last time that inyo
americans went to any of these countries
for not a damn thing wouldn't have been
smarter to donate
wouldn't have been smarter to give like
1.3 billion to chicago and fix that
i'd like to have a committee deal that
money out watch out that money spent but
well
trust me every single one of our cities
needs enhanced so invest in here
what you've been talking about uh uh
our grid what about our grid our grid
how about this too um there there are a
few countries
that are charging us to put our military
in their country
i got one for you on that base
yeah it's like wait a minute does that
really make sense that we're paying a
country to protect them
in italy where i was stationed at
in aviano we rent
the base area all that stuff where we
put all the buildings on the flight line
everywhere the italians can fly in and
fly out we protect
all of italy with our navy and our air
force we protect it all
yet we rent from the government
that land that our base is on that's
crap
and you know what i found out the most
odd about this entire thing
the democrats are so obsessed with
keeping us in our house and wearing
masks so that way they can save
everybody's lives
and make sure that we're healthy from
the virus and i didn't see any they're
gonna send the money off to other
countries
but no money was put into any medical
research no money was put into our
schools
no money was positive yeah they're
giving money to schools they aren't
giving money to schools
well that's good that's good but it's
not
there's a way about that and i'm sure
it's going to just be wasted
but you know all these comorbilities
everybody has you think they'd be
putting more money into the awareness
you never hear the the science tells us
where your mask wear your mask right
that's what they say
but do you ever hear them talk about
what we can do to boost our immune
system so we don't get the coronavirus
do you know any of those things i've
never once heard the ag come out and say
anything i've never once heard felchi to
say
what you can do to boost your immune
system because they don't care
and that's the shameful part about all
this what you know what i've learned
from all this
that they don't care about us i wanted
to say another word i wanted to say
another word
they do and and and give a flying about
us
and i know and i know some people say
some people say call them
but many of their voicemails are filled
up
yeah they don't answer them they don't
listen to them or
you know you can go to dc if you can get
in to see them
i mean because they hide behind those
doors in washington dc
oh oh oh i have a meeting scheduled
when when the meeting's in the bathroom
i got to drop the kids off at the pool
they're no different than the boss from
um
i saw a meme out there it had nothing to
do with this well it did but it didn't
but every all those people up there in
congress remind me of the boss
from national land prunes christmas
vacation remember how they had to go get
them
and kidnap them and bring them to his
senses we watched that last night
they put the bow tie on him they thought
he was kicking his butt as he
is actually a symbol for congress and
the senate because remember at the
beginning he doesn't know your name
he gets your name messed up he doesn't
care about the gifts you're giving him
he doesn't care about you whatsoever he
just cares about himself
and what did you get yeah you got a
jelly of the month club
that's what you got and that's exactly
what they're doing to us we just got
jelly of the months
right and even his wife said oh honey no
you
didn't yeah well yeah i messed up when i
got
caught and i got caught i actually
looked
yeah at the families that it hurt see
everybody out there in washington dc
they'll give two flying flips about you
and your family
they just care about getting elected get
re-elected
and getting that 175 000
a year paycheck and you heard casey
cortez
she complained before she got her first
check how mom called before an apartment
she got a first check of 3 500 a week
[Music]
big money but let me tell you something
boy
do it when you get going um
my boy yes it's one of those things man
i feel like i'm in the ring huh come on
i'm bouncing off the ropes
look guys we would have surprised
we i mean we would have a surplus
if we would stop spending money that we
don't have
in all these other foreign countries and
in this country too
there are a whole lot of social programs
out there that don't work they haven't
worked for decades
but they keep on throwing money at it
those
social programs need to be shut down
they need to be shut down but there's
another thing that happened too
when they passed those two omnibus bills
and i and some people saw it many people
didn't but some people
saw it is when those two omnibus bills
got spent schumer was like like the
penguin from joker oh
we need to man we got a whole lot of
other stuff that we can do now
yeah yeah it's like they just want to
keep on spending spending spending
spinning
and it's and if americans were
really pissed off like we are right now
real really
honestly this should be an x-rated
show this is gonna be uh yeah we all
tried swearing
oh yeah there's a whole lot of stuff
that we could be saying that
uh that we'd probably be spending a
couple weeks on altar
repenting for but
we're trying to keep it cool seriously
we're trying to keep it cool because we
because we like y'all we enjoy y'all and
we don't want y'all to think
that we're some heathen but
if more americans would be pissed off at
the way that congress is treating us
and stop voting in these sons of
biscuits stop voting them in
stan i mean show them that you got the
power
well okay well wayne what else should we
do start getting elected on local
levels and community councils
and start changing things but the main
thing is
vote out ted cruz vote out rand paul
but and but those are good ones yeah
vote them out and then
make them governor of your state if
they're so good right yeah
make them governor of your state but
vote in somebody else
congress is supposed to be a revolving
thing new ideas
um new new ways of doing things so that
the country keeps moving
the country's been stagnant because we
have old ass people up there
and this is not a knock against old
people but guess what it is in a way
because there's
old people that keep bernie sanders keep
trying well
i don't know no i know new ways of doing
things
no you don't nope and here's the numbers
just real quick
in the 244 years of america's existence
244 years
we currently have what three anywhere
from 330 to 380
million people in this country okay this
year 350 million people
in this country and in 244 years
4 000 have passed through the halls of
congress
four you need term limits you have to
have term limits
i don't care what anybody says that is
one of the most important things you
have to have
when you get comfortable in a situation
you know what happens
you stop reading through 6 000 pages of
a bill
and then you just sign it when you get
comfortable when you get comfortable
you say things about a sitting president
that you shouldn't say nancy pelosi
okay when you get comfortable you start
to like china
money that's what happens when you get
comfortable in a situation
you make deals with the devil because
you know you can because you can't be
voted out
because you know that you can't be
terminated term limits it starts with
term limits and it ends with term limits
it's frustrating guys and i i know i'm
with you all
jim jordan's gonna be out kevin mccarthy
it's gonna be out term limits we're
gonna lose some of these great devin
nunes
gonna be out we're gonna lose some of
these great uh uh patriotic americans
however
we've got to lose them to double down
and get
twice as many on the top right
and like they said congress will never
vote for term limits well then that
maybe there needs to be another branch
of government and
that's actually created you want to
create another party
let's create another brand right but you
don't
but you look congress congress doesn't
need to pass term limits
you vote you have travel limits every
election yeah you got term limits in
your hands right yes
yes you don't need a look i mean oh man
i don't know how many
times i've i've heard that well we need
congress congress isn't going to do it
you know why because
they aren't they aren't trying to stop
the the um the money spigot from putting
money in
pockets they are making boo-coo
money off of andover fest and
oh my god yes over fist look there's
women in it they look from swimming
it's coming out of their it it's their
drawing
they're out their eyes and everywhere
wherever no but here's the thing uh for
for those of you who attempted to run
like our good friend k
kim klasik uh for those of you who
attempted to run to overthrow a democrat
overthrow rhino what not
in 2018 and 2020 here's how you run
2021 here's how you run 2022 whether
trump is in or not
here's how you run you run on an
anti-corruption
platform and get elected
against republican guess democrat i am
running anti-corruption to clean the
hell up out of this swamp
but you'd have to be a phenomenon
because honestly these people that
keep getting re-elected they're almost i
hate to say it it's like they're
they're buying they're rigging their own
elections anyways in their in their
cities
yeah the united states postal service
you know they get that right
right and you get intermingled with the
people that are voting for you and then
you make like i said deals with the
devil
with them and then all of a sudden they
have to vote for you and their entire
you know uh group has to vote for you so
really you're up against it
it takes it to leave ill hand omar
and then uh what's that what's all
girl's name shaped her head
i don't know i know you're talking about
i don't think she shaved her head she
has a disease
that pectoria or whatever disease
whatever loses her hair
it's like me making fun of somebody's
mom and the guy's like oh my mom's dead
no he didn't oh come on i didn't know
i didn't know she shaved her head she
did weird
no she didn't she didn't darionic grande
what's her name
she's a singer ayanna presley
anna presley
[Music]
look and and i know and i know some
people are marching
uh to dc on the six uh
let let me say this because i have some
friends that
are uh in charge of that and
and moving along with it uh marching is
marching
to dc is the topical response you know
how
topical cream if if you have a rash
marching to dc
and speaking is a topical response
it's great i mean and you know it gets
you
a a couple interviews and stuff like
that and
uh it looks good but if you don't
have anything else attached to it that's
underneath
yeah you need something invasive the
cancer metastasizes
right yeah you need something invasive
then when you leave and you better leave
before it gets dark
that's another thing
if you don't leave before it gets dark
you're gonna get your ass whooped
so uh but if
it doesn't have anything attached to it
your feel good ends around four or five
o'clock
and then you go back home still pissed
off
because your march didn't do anything
because cocaine mitch still does what
come king mitch does
he just he told his people leo he told
his people
middlebury
marches marches worked in the 60s
it worked because we didn't have twitter
and facebook
right right and we didn't have twitter
and facebook marches now but yeah it
shows your presence there it shows that
there's people in numbers
but again like you said it's a topical
response it's not invasive
it doesn't heal the cancer it doesn't
cure the cancer
maybe again we're in the beginning
stages of learning this new world i
guess that we're in where we have to
do all this to try to get what we need
or what we want to become america again
and i don't think marches are going to
cut it i think that that's just what we
know
and so that's what we instinctively do
hey we don't like that so that's march
and try to get our way but there has
there has to be more to it
and i think that if we would have
hindsight like
brian always says 50 50 hindsight 2020.
if we would have realized this maybe six
months ago that maybe a march isn't
going to work and yes i understand s
smoker that twitter and facebook are
compromised but you're missing my point
my point was
that marching and us screaming about it
on twitter screaming about it on twitter
believe it or not works harder than what
marching does notice that
he vetoed that bill and you can't tell
me that he didn't look online first
i'm talking about trump he didn't even
tell me yet yeah no not veto it but he's
not coming back
yeah and you can't tell me he didn't
look online
exactly but remember he also said he
wasn't even aware about the march that
happened three weeks ago
so trump is more aware about what's
going on in twitter even though it's
compromised i get that
but he's looking more at what we're
saying on twitter than what he
sees when you're standing outside with a
sign outside the white house
that march isn't as impactful as what a
tweet is impactful when you tweet
something out
and you can get 23 000 tweets on it and
it's just a random person without a blue
check mark
saying don't send this bill through that
is more powerful than standing outside
the white house
with a sign because they're so used to
it they're ignoring it they're becoming
immune to these signs and these people
marching and really it's
eye roll you have to be in by eight
o'clock you know or you know antifa
comes out so
marching i think you'll see will be a
thing of the past
to prove your point about marching and
for all of you who go
to dc every january in the blizzard
in the freezing cold i understand your
car microphone yeah
yeah i understand your cause i know why
you do it
however uh weigh that
in your marches weigh that with the
bills
and the progress and the movement
towards the eradication
of half of the black community through
abortion
and someone said are you discouraging
patriots to show their presence no i'm
saying patriots be more coordinated
and be more like if you want to do if
you want to go to war you want to go to
the mattresses
then coordinate it a march holding a
sign and holding your phone saying stop
the vote isn't going to stop the vote
so do coordinated action um
i don't know kelly koran okay okay well
i'll tell you what
no we're not telling you to march but
what is your march gonna do
well now that don't bring your guns and
don't bring animals that's not a good
market i'm just saying
more coordinated responses more
coordinated responses
no but my thing is and
and and and and leo responded in a great
way but my response
is what is your march going to do
right craig mossy says i think our
activism
tactics need to change yeah yeah yeah
that's exactly what i'm saying i'm
saying a better coordinated response you
really want to get something done
you can't just tweet out to a couple
people hey let's go march in dc
that's not what a war is you want a war
you want to start a war with the
republicans
you want to fight for donald trump then
fight for him
you have to be coordinated you have to
understand what it takes to get there
and the marches so far haven't changed
anything so let's step back and figure
out
what else can you do i don't know what
that answer is get a coordinated team
and figure it out it's not always just
about guns and rioting figure it out
there's better ways that's all i'm
saying getting in a politician's face
no don't get in a politician's face
don't use twitter as a crutch figure out
creative ways how do you think that
we've won so many wars in the past
it was with creative ways think of a
creative way
you got to do something different but
still still i want to know
from those that feel like we might be
discouraging people to march which we
i i don't care if you march or not you
march
if you want to march but i want to know
why are you marching
what do you expect to happen and so s
smoker says you're saying a million
people around
the pond won't make a statement no
nothing right now
but it's not doing anything it's not
doing anything the only statement that
it will make
is we were there we took selfies
together
we had
that's it you know what all uh all of
the
um lawmakers that you need to talk to
aren't coming out to meet you
so they are still in the halls of well
actually they're probably home because
of christmas vacation
so but here's the thing they're looking
at doing another march on the sixth
right i know i got the call too i said
no
it's not gonna be physically possible
for me to do it i'm just not gonna be
there on the six it's not gonna happen
sorry two weekends ago there was a march
i know i had some close friends that
went
and they were there and they told me
they'll never go back to dc
until it gets cleaned up because two
weekends ago it was an
absolute show and there were
hundreds of thousands they claimed a
million
but at least a half a million at least a
half a second i just played this
hold on hold on at least a half million
people showed up two weekends ago
and if this is the first time you're
hearing about it that's why we're
complaining
about marches right and remember if you
keep doing the same thing over and over
again expecting the same
different results what's that called
identity right
redundancy too i mean but that's my
whole point how many people
realized that there was a half million
people and i'm not talking about the
pictures you saw on social media
did you hear that there was a huge march
on dc
two weekends ago you know what's gonna
happen the person that succeeds this is
the next person that thinks of a better
idea will be a billionaire or a
millionaire
the next person that succeeds okay and
the democrats
are and i'll give them credit for this
they're crafty they're crafty when they
can come up with things
you know right now you realize that they
are writing postcards well before
before the vote in georgia they're
writing postcards to democrats all
across the country
democrats are writing postcards to
democrats telling them why they should
vote in this election
all these famous people they're asking
for their birthday for you to send
birthday money
to the georgia representative or the
people that are running in georgia
this is they get creative here's another
thing too
uh the the huge marches that they had
against president trump
their resists marches did that do
anything
it didn't slow trump down he still
didn't craft
bills to stop trump he still remained
president
right there were no bills to stop him
from what he was doing
look at the black lives matter marches
they still haven't had a meeting with
joe biden
nothing has changed apparently they're
not going to either
but again folks what we're talking about
and what leah just mentioned
you got to come up with creative
inventive ideas and i'll throw another
one out there
just as democrats it was a
a very good strategy the way that just
democrats that was a great yeah said we
are going to go out and we are going to
uh casting call yeah everybody that we
could possibly casting call
and we're going to find the most uh
eccentric
creative outspoken uh girls
boys whoever that fits the mode of what
we're looking for
and we're going to run that against
democrats that are not hard enough
and as i talked to a good friend on
the youtubes who does this for a living
he says guys i watched as ocasio-cortez
and the justice democrats ran her
campaign if they did
it as if they copied
uh what i told them to do
and it's it's it's and i'll tell you a
good way to hold somebody accountable
for something
is to put a magnifying glass on them and
how do you put a magnifying glass on
somebody
you assign a certain amount of people to
them so you know how like elvis presley
had a fan club scott baio has a fan club
well you know what you need you need it
it's not a fan club
it's just a group of people and each one
each
they're assigned to each member of
congress and you air their dirty laundry
you air what they're doing well
and then you send it to them and you do
it every day and you continue to do it
and that keeps them in if you give them
a spine you have to give them a spine
that holds them accountable so you want
to get people out there
then you need to have 10 to 50 people
that are on
mitch mcconnell that are on lindsey
graham that can tell his bad and tell
his good there should have been somebody
on newsome as soon as he walked in that
restaurant
boom video out on him look at this just
like there was right
but then there needs to be 10 people
that are doing that every day with all
these politicians
i promise you their butts will get
straightened out real quick holding
people accountable
and showing the proof of it follow them
around like like they're famous
yeah accountable oh yeah you do yeah
exactly paparazzi
yeah why do you think famous people get
caught everything they do is out in
the open you know why it's because they
have followers that do that
they have people that do that march
marching
is more than like i said
taking pictures and uh
going back home still pissed off but
telling people but i marched
that it's more i mean being active is
more than that now
especially now i mean there's a whole
lot more
uh now the bond army
the bond army i don't know if y'all
heard about this before but the bond
army marched on dc
and stayed they took
tents and stayed on the washington mall
they did because uh
back during the day veterans had to go
to dc to get paid
right but something happened with that
so
there were tents man and nowhere else to
go they were
they were living right on the grassy
um on the grass and everything that's
more than just marching
that's more than just marching and
that's and that's what i'm saying it
has to be more than that now if i was a
billionaire
i would be doing this but you know
you got charlie kirk and his group
having str uh uh so-called strippers up
after
glorified strippers glorified strippers
uh
uh shooting money yet guys i have to
admit something i have to admit
something when i watch that video
i thought that was wuhan shooting money
out to people
i did i did not know that this was
happening over here because no one had
masks on so i immediately thought oh
right then i saw these girls dressed in
these really tight outfits shooting
money out and i'm like
see-through outfits by the way yeah i'm
like wow how does this represent the
conservative party in a
positive way and show that they can take
this party seriously
if you're like 16 trying to figure out
what you want to do
i i thought it was wuhan at first in
fact if you've got a resort to sex
and money to garner a following
yeah to a conservative following i know
you're using the demon you're using
the the dark side to attract people to
the light
that don't work they're going to turn
away
yeah why didn't they just have hunter
biden emcee the whole thing
isn't that what he's all about yeah
well that's what i'm saying i mean
there's no difference i don't know i
wasn't real impressed
i was disappointed we were we were part
of it
we were talking earlier about uh
the uh the money situation with the
stimulus
uh i watched this on i'm not gonna play
all of it
but let me um let me play this
the president's move on this does put
republicans in a
in a pretty difficult position what do
they do
well you know it really is a problem
becky because as you guys have talked
about earlier this morning
mcconnell really wants this stimulus
bill through now
because um in georgia the two republican
senators there
running for re-election have been
hammered by the democrats
uh over their party standing in the way
of a stimulus bill
uh and uh right now that if you look at
the latest polling from there both the
democratic
uh you know contenders are are leading
so
uh obviously mcconnell has a big
challenge there um
i really don't know what he's going to
do um uh you know
i'm sure right now there's furious
negotiations with the white house
uh asking the president what the hell
are you doing um
where do you think this is to go and
well we'll see we'll see ladies and
gentlemen i i don't know i don't know
the pandemic's impact on the economy
includes a staggering statistic about
one billion hotel rooms unsold
by christmas arsene modi has more on
that sema i
i gotta say i had to do a double take
when i saw that in your intro a jaw
dropping number carl with fewer people
traveling this holiday season
hotels are struggling to fill their
rooms the average
occupancy rate in the u.s has fallen to
this month compared to the 60 percent
rate this time
last year the industry now getting close
to hitting a milestone
it never thought it would see nearly 1
billion unsold rooms according to data
from str
and the migration to suburbs the decline
in international tourism this year
that's hitting big cities particularly
hard chicago houston where more than
half of hotels financed through the
commercial mortgage-backed securities
market
are currently delinquent in new york
high profile properties from the hilton
times square
omni berkshire have permanently shut
their doors after missing
a series of debt payments now down in
north north carolina
vinay patel owner of nine hotels says
he's not not only dealing with empty
rooms but
a lack of pricing power
now if i get a hotel down in
charlottesville we've got average rate
of 150
and all of a sudden now the rate goes
down to 99 to 100
so you're talking about one-third of
revenue just displaced right there
patel doesn't see demand returning to
pre-covered levels for another
year or so and then the question is how
does a vaccine change that timeline
you
people are hurting boy don't vaccinate
don't change that timeline especially
when you are saying that you gotta keep
a mask on
and six foot distancing and i got we got
kelly on on
the periscope that said what kind of
party did turning point usa have
conservatives slam turning point usa for
event using
bang girls to shoot out money
that's the party they have there you go
as for the hotels i'll just tell you
those
the windows most hotels i go to you
can't open the windows they're sealed
shut right
yeah they are yeah yeah okay
right so they're sealed shut and it's
all shared ventilation i'm assuming in
hotels you don't get your own private
air ventilating
through your hotel filter it's right
here yeah it's clean
because you don't smell smoke through
different rooms i understand that but
what i'm saying is
the bishop to brian the bones no you
know i don't do that kind of garbage
guys
you knew about the smoke though
i know a lot of people
i know a lot of people that won't stay
in a hotel room because they just
they just feel like it's probably one of
the least places that they want to go
during covent because
of how it works you can't open a window
and they feel like they should
they can't so they don't so it's down
get the app open our app speaking about
open windows
open open our app
oh someone's sharing the app
guys that's what that's what you got to
do right now get the app uh you never
know what's going to happen on the
twitters the facebooks the youtubes
i mean you never know what's going to
happen but you do know what's going to
happen
when you get the app you know you're
always going to get the show
you know you're always going to be able
to connect with us through text
you'll be able to call us you get your
local weather
and traffic you'll get all the news
article you get
everything if you get the app that's
what you know to be sure
and it's easy to get the app you have to
just go to google play or your app store
type in wayne dupree
podcast it downloads within a second uh
and again
you can watch on the podcast live or
watch previously recorded
podcasts you won't see a podcast on
there on how to royal rule
a joint that brian makes though so
unfortunately you won't get it
no i don't make choice no he doesn't oh
i do make jokes
i do i make butt joints i'll make a
buttress joint yeah
welding and uh somebody's working
[Laughter]
[Music]
i have a calendar event on my work
computer to watch the show
love to show guess what becky you just
won 50 bucks
becky
[Music]
becky m now ladies and gentlemen y'all
have to
make sure that your email is legit
because if because if you wait hold on
ryan
don't do what i did no i didn't do
anything okay how do you do that yeah
yeah change don't do anything
[Laughter]
uh i got that from clinton if
quitting scoofy for the next for the
next uh 10 minutes for the next 10
minutes we're doing a little
we aren't going to go fully extend it
but for the next 10 minutes send us a
message
with the with the app tomorrow we're
gonna have call-ins
but i have three more 50-dollar payments
that i can send out becky m is one so
becky
m i'll be sending you uh
a response so hurry up download there
she is becky m she says woohoo i love
the show
becky m so download the app right now
again
wayne dupree podcast download it and
send
a message right as soon as you start
typing in
i got an an iphone as soon as you start
typing in wayne space
d it'll automatically i mean there is no
app
you can yes you can chat on the app
because you're going to be watching it
via youtube so you'll be able to chat
you'll see once you get on there you'll
be able to
click on the show and you'll be able to
see how you can chat joy
joy from yesterday well actually
kellyanne
make sure i let me make sure i took care
of it
kellyanne
okay hold on joey got paid yesterday
yeah yeah paul
paul is getting his mail don deckman
used venmo
so his is gonna be after christmas
and there was one more
killing in uh i want to make sure
i got that one but coming in what you
have to do again download that wayne to
pre-podcast download it now
send a message and you could be a winner
of 50 dollars right right now we're
taking care of business right now
we're getting people paid mm-hmm
and this and this is money that y'all
have sent in to help
us and i decided that i was going to
turn around
for this script i this first time that
we've been able to do it like that but
um i decided i was going to turn it
around
and send it back out to some individuals
that might be in the need or
but we wanted it to be with our lord
listeners and the reason why
i'm not blasting this all over social
media is because then we have people
out of the woodworks that don't even
listen to the show that are just jump
right
and try people that hate the show trying
to get our money oh yeah
yeah yeah and we aren't we aren't doing
it like that so right
um our first
our first winner oh yeah
let me let me bring that up while i
search for anything um the show is being
sponsored by my pillow
thank you thank you leah blue eyes
yeah we are being sponsored by my pillow
so that means you get a special code
word
that's right the special code word is
wayne capital w-a-y-n-e just type that
in whenever you're shopping on
mypillow.com
click the radio specials and then fill
up your shopping cart you can get
bed sheets or the giza sheets are
amazing the giza dream sheets
uh you can get some towel sets they're
buy one get one free
the dream sheets are also buy one get
one free the they have
wonderful robes that are soft amazing
cozy
warm robes and of course they're special
their favorite they're my pillows
you can get them firm less firm more
firm they have all different types
so if you just go to mypillow.com radio
specials type in the promo code wayne
you'll be able to go on and get special
offers that other people
aren't able to get and you can call the
800 number 8890532
if you're like me and and don't order
things online like that i like to call
and talk
just tell them when to present you and i
can tell you my favorite are the towels
they soak up the water they're soft to
the touch but they don't leave all those
fuzzies on you
and they're big i thought that it was
just going to be regular sized towel but
they're actually a really
big towel and the buy one get one free
so i think that that's
a great uh plus with that as well uh and
then brian can tell you about the
my pillow topper brian you love your
topper don't you
love the topper i was actually thinking
about getting i got this match was
80 off just for sears went out of
business now i understand why sears went
out of business
that's about three years ago we got this
the four years ago got this thing so i'm
thinking about getting a whole new
mattress
and then i had an opportunity to get the
topper and i'm like you know what
let's do the tapper freaking get a whole
new mattress see what happens right
got the three-inch topper and i'm
telling you
it's like a whole brand new mattress and
again the only thing that i can compare
to because i
i don't have money i don't come for
money and the only thing i compared to
is the time that i was treated
uh to the trump doral all
inclusive resort they have exclusive
mattresses
only made for them that's the only thing
i compared to
them waking up in the morning in a good
mood
right and we had i know for those that
weren't on the
show a few days ago we had a listener
actually message me and talk about her
she's not her sleep pattern was terrible
she'd wake up almost every night at 3
a.m and she's been doing that for years
so she decided to take the plunge and
get the pillows
and the sheets and she did and the first
night she still woke up but she said by
the fifth night or the third night
she was sleeping a sound sleep the whole
way through and that she really could
feel the difference in her neck
with the my pillow so if you're having
neck issues you're having sleeping
issues
get the pillow it works and for as long
as we spend sleeping in our beds
it's important that you have top quality
uh
materials somebody mentioned the other
day something actually sleeps on the
left side
was that yeah she sleeps on the left
side right and as a for a left side
sleeper i'll show you here
it's right here right yes i agree 100.
this is unbelievable right and you get
that support right here a lot of pillows
will just give you support here
test out your pillow tonight whenever
you lay on it you'll see that your
support you can stick your hand the
whole way through
with the my pillow it supports so much
it stops your hand yeah so
having to fold my pillow up right i'm
not realizing that
i didn't know that if you bought the
right pillow
it would work yeah and some people you
know pillows
people just take them for granted they
don't even look at their pillow
but if you actually examine your pillow
you'll see it's dirty it's musty it's
collecting dust mites you wouldn't
believe how many dust mites are on your
pillow
throw it out get a my pillow because you
can throw them in the dryer
right they're walkable they're actually
guaranteed washable they're that durable
you throw them in the dryer wayne does a
little trick where he throws them in the
dryer gets it nice and warm and puffy
and fluffy
and then lays on it so use codeword
wayne
mypillow.com all right um we have
three more winners we have three more
winners holy smoke
i did say and thank you for everybody
downloading an app this is not the first
this is not the last time
that we're doing this like i said
tomorrow we're going to open up the
phone lines
today we're doing it this way um
we i'm next week next week i might even
extend it into going into the new year i
just
it's just how we are doing with our with
our patreon funds and everything like
that and if you are
on patreon let me put this out to you
real quick
don't delete us just because it's
christmas
whatever you give or whatever you have
been given if you want to move it down
to five dollars
do that but don't but don't
delete us because we still have to pay
our bills
and uh do things like this
to and and you in in
in all honesty you're helping somebody
else so you know
you're also helping somebody else for um
christmas
um but uh the winners are getting 50
so becky already becky becky
m that i mentioned before uh
let's see i think this is uh
okay i think this is laura
i'm sorry i i i responded them to them
by email
but it didn't carry everything over so
um
okay well i'll do
i'll do it like this l davis
congratulations i just emailed you l
davison
76. oh l davis oh 876. i sent you an
email
i'll take uh i will contact you after
the show uh
and we'll go from there a-n-c-e
mom a acne no no
a-n-c-e mom congratulations
i also sent your email t goins
also sent your email now notice i didn't
put your whole email out there
or y'all my address but what is it
[Music]
i'm not going to do anything to paris i
promise
and becky's already responding to me by
email so
great job congratulations you got her
so um again l davis zero 876
um a-n-c-e mom t
goins and becky m thank you for list for
watching the show and being part
of the wayne dupree show tomorrow we'll
be doing the same thing
that's our christmas eve special uh
christmas eve
you better be dressed festive i want to
see you
reindeer ears elf ears i want to see
green and red
sparkling off ya yes wayne even you
a little cutie patootie elf
i told my son this morning i said son
two more sleepy
times two more sleepy times that's right
listen here woman you're josslyn you
listen here
man you're dressing cute tomorrow
whether you like it or not and i think
the audience would like it too they're
all saying santa wayne
they want to see santa wayne
just saying you gotta do it now your
audience won it they've spoke
they've spoke wayne it's my show
so you got to be santa wayne do whatever
i want to do no
not on christmas again
do whatever i want to do when i want to
do it no i take my ball and go home and
play with myself
um you've been smoking too much
what's that got to do with we you need
to you need your analysis test
[Laughter]
in the wrong neighborhood there's
all right uh um let's start
i watched a christmas story last night
with my daughter for the first time she
was on
a christmas story a christmas story with
a little kid
yeah you know shoot your eye out yeah
she watched it for the first time
she's seven okay she watched it for the
first time she loved it
um she loved it whenever it was drink
your ovaltine she laughed at that part
and when she
you know she asked you what overtame was
though yes she did and i just
yeah and i told her and she said that
sounds gross but you know what the
neatest part was last year i got to go
i got i thought it was chocolate milk
with vitamins like with it tasted really
good it's chocolate man
okay well last year i got to actually go
to the christmas story house and see it
and i learned a lot of fun facts about
it so it was really neat to tell her
and for anybody who's going to watch a
christmas story this year now you'll
think back to what i said today
at the end of it when the husband and
wife and the old man and the wife are
sitting
at the end and she puts her arm around
him and they look out the window and
it's all dark and the christmas trees
just lit up and they're looking out the
main picture window
snow's falling and it looks gorgeous
well it's actually not snow
it didn't snow that year in ohio so they
had to use
mashed potato flakes with a huge fan so
when you see that fall
it's actual mashed potato flakes falling
and
she got a kick out of that she thought
that was funny so
there's your funny fact ovaltine
drink your ovaltine and then he says
and he says biscuit he said drink your
ovaties
son of a biscuit that's what he says
and it wasn't the f word it was not
blown no they bleep it out guys by the
way yeah
yeah uh quentin's upset because you gave
a spoiler alert day rally
how's that spoiler alert it wasn't even
part of the movie just mashed potatoes
flying around
get over it how about how about when the
dogs got in the house
oh that's great emma yeah she loved that
part too my kids won't stop saying it
she won't stop either now she won't stop
you're right i forgot about that
america on 34th street it's wonderful
life absolutely black plane
two great ones yeah absolutely too great
yeah
yeah i mean that uh
it's a wonderful life is a good one um
grumpy old men y'all have to watch
grumpy old men
uh walter matthau and john lemon great
movie
uh two great actors that lived
super long yeah with such great talent
with the likes of
kids i like him and dennis you can't see
that kind of talent in hollywood no you
don't
this doesn't exist no i mean that's
uh and they weren't rare they weren't
super political but
um back then i know it was a wonderful
thing but
hollywood back then was when you saw
hollywood
uh premiere or whatnot you you looked on
those
actors like damn they're almost like
gods almost
because well not guides but
they were so glamorous that it just yeah
glamorous look
wow and now when you look at it now it's
like yeah
and i can do that yeah now you see
they dress up like they're at a strip
show yeah come on
i saw you down at the strip show last
weekend dressed like that
or worse or they have
um the guys who who
i have to take that woman plunge and
dress like a woman
terrible most men in hollywood
have dressed like a woman in a movie and
i'm sorry
and they probably like johnny dab uh
homeless
shiv is not a thing stop
dressing like a homeless person you're
insulting homeless people
there's something mentally wrong a lot
of these people that you're talking
about they have mental issues
just going to say it thank you leah
john travolta well he's he
he's on the other team he's switching
that's hard for me i just don't
understand how your wife i
don't understand how your wife passes
away and then three weeks later you're
doing a commercial
for a cell phone company because you're
a switcher because you do whatever
yeah yeah oh definitely well he got in
trouble did you know that he got in
trouble for touching uh
trying to make advances to a male
massage
yes he did he got in trouble
yeah i got thrown out of court no they
he settled out of court didn't get
thrown out of court it was in court and
then the guy said yeah i'll take your
money instead we won't go to court
that's no trouble yeah john travolta
yeah he dances he sings he's a little
he's literally got an airport at his
house he'll do whatever he wants
there's support besides guy just wanted
some change that's
all no john wanted something else
apparently
there's no happy ending out there in
hollywood i don't like them
i don't like any of them yeah when you
go to a regular bar and the bartender
comes around the bar and it's a dude
with no shirt on
something i did like i did like mrs
doubtfire you remember mrs doubtfire
hello
yes terry i did like mrs doubtfire that
was good
no no i can't i mean i can't watch men
in dresses
i can't do it i don't care whether
they're white or black i don't care
i did i just took it hey i'll tell you
what all that laughter there my god out
of robin williams
that took a toll on him yeah yeah i mean
look
i call them transmissioners
nothing like when training acts up in
public man
i call them transmissioners and it
breaks down in public like that
oh boy
sounds like country song
[Music]